this email we got was from the United
States Department of Agriculture and
they were plowing up crops across the
nation
dumping milk chickens and hogs and I
believed this email was to prepare us
for that possibility with cows why is it
such a big deal where people are given a
push back of water meters coming from as
a consumer you don't know what you're
buying it oppresses our prices because
there's no competition for it why should
the consumer care we are importing beef
and we are destroying our harvests at a
time when people don't have jobs is it
similar to what Walmart did - a lot of
mom-and-pop shops and put them out of
business it's the same thing
who's the Amazon of your world I'm not
sure there is an Amazon of our world
maybe there's an idea right there
we don't want the government getting in
on our beef industry
sonny Perdue he's a globalist two of our
four main beef packers are Brazilian own
and they've been caught in these
fraudulent cases in their own countries
what do you think they're doing the
United States
Tyson food Cargill jbs national beef
those are the four you're talking about
there will be a takeover of our industry
and then a lot of these producers will
become serfs to the Oleg Archy and I
think that's where we're headed we have
to be able to feed the world at a
problem we can't do it at a loss who
fills my shoes now in this time and age
nobody only multinational corporations
you can't tell me what card I come from
a family we all work hard there are
smart people in this industry they're
innovative that's why we have the best
product in the world could you easily
sell others to consider getting into
your industry today unless you marry it
are inherited you ain't gonna have it
it's financially impossible
[Music]
did you ever think you will make it I
feel like it takes sweet victory I know
this slice meant for me yeah why would
you bet on Goliath oh we got plenty
value Kaman given values contagious this
world of entrepreneurs we can't no value
the haters honey run homie look what I
become
[Music]
my guest today is an American cattle
rancher shad Sullivan who a video
recently went viral getting a millions
of views were a bunch of people reposted
and he said a couple lines that caught
my attention juice and ice and millions
of chickens dumping milks a
depopulating fat you know the cattle
ready to harvest and I looked at that
stuff and I listened to his message a
few times and I said Marty want you to
see if he can get a hold of shad and
shad and Mario got on the phone together
and and shad you is the famous line who
was the line he told you said don't josh
me not doing that I'm just joshing you
that just tells you where he lives he
lives in North Texas and we want to kind
of find out what's going on industry
today so shad thank you for making the
time to be on that Amon you're welcome
thank you so what what happened from you
going out there and giving your message
and just assumed some of the people that
are watching this haven't heard you what
happens to give us an update on what's
going on in your world well the reason I
did the video was we were working out in
the field and we got a an email alert
and this email we got was from the
United States Department of Agriculture
and in that email it said they would be
forming a group of people to come out
and help with help producers move their
animals that were unable to move to a
marketing system an alternative
marketing system and I told myself right
then I'm like well there's not many
alternative marketing systems right now
thanks to komen and then it went on to
say these groups of individuals
comprised the state veterinarians and
other state officials would help in the
depopulation and disposal of said
animals didn't say cattle that said
animals if the need arose so it kind of
set me off and I'm like I don't like the
sound of this that made me mad I had
just remembered two days before we
imported some cow some beef from Africa
and I knew what the supply chain in
other industries was doing I mean we had
seen what what they were plowing up
crops across the nation
dumping milk chickens and hogs and this
I believed this email was to prepare us
for that possibility with cow my dad had
told me about the 1930s and 1950s when
they had to depopulate due to drought
and disease now this is a whole
different circumstance but it is one
that is coming could come to fruition
even now because the Komen has created a
problem in our processing facilities
that these workers are afraid to come to
work due to the cocoa bed and so that's
creating a bottleneck or a backlog of
cattle that need to be harvested and I
think right now we could be close to a
million head that you know some are
seven weeks out from from their original
harvest date and that's causing the
backlog or the backup of meat in the
system we can't get the supply of beef
through the system to the consumer there
are cattle you know our supply of cattle
live cattle is great the demand is great
it's getting it through the system that
is has become a problem and so that's
what really got me frustrated and I said
you know we are importing beef and we
are destroying our harvests at a time
when people don't have jobs and that's
not the American Way it does it didn't
make sense and they were destined off
the books and the protocol was there for
that to start happening and so I was
just a little bit upset by that
I just off-the-cuff did the video I'm
not a guy that usually does things like
that and it went what they call viral
and and here we sit today I told my wife
I said maybe I take that off I don't
want to panic people our food supply is
safe we have issues with it and she said
no the American people need to hear the
truth and so we have some industries out
there that don't want to you know speak
the truth and and that's how I got to
you today how does that affect the
average person so imagine I'm not in
your world
know what's going on all I do is I
either watch CNN MSNBC or I either watch
Fox or I get my news from social media
I'm one of those three how am i
impacting by what's going on to you
well you're impacted through by a supply
issue and a food safety issue so what
has happened down through the years is
our federal government has allowed
acquisition acquisitions and mergers of
multinational corporations to take over
our food supply systems so in the beef
industry for example we have four
companies that control 85 percent of the
beef cattle supply chain okay so they're
there we are putting our eggs in one
basket so to speak so what happened is
the Kovach come in we get these sick
people and because our eggs are in one
basket we have the inability to process
those animals to get to this to the
consumer right so the power those
companies have funnels down to the
consumer you're no longer able to get
your product number one number two they
the safety they're importing less
quality and lower quality beef into our
supply and mixing it onto our honor
supply which is increasing their profits
opressing our profits and kind of
gouging the consumer so you don't know
exactly what kind of product you're
getting that's it's a it's a it does
come down to a food safety issue and a
Liberty issue as far as I'm concerned so
chat based on what I'm seeing there's
four different business models here you
got the producers at the beginning then
you got processors then distributors
then retailers right yes and there's
even more to that so you have the
cow-calf producer that that's the man
who owns the cow and they have a baby
calf is that what you do that's what you
know that's not what I do myself okay so
there's the cow-calf producer those
calves grow to a certain weight we they
wean them off of the cow and then they
go to a man who I am called a stocker
operator and so I buy that calf and I
grow that calf to a certain weight and
my part of it I do it on grass so I grow
them on
to a certain way say 800 pounds and then
I sell those animals to what they call
the feedlot industry the feedlot
industry can be captive supply there's
all sorts of different aspects to that
industry but they grow them to a certain
weight and then and prepare them for
harvest and then you have the harvest
harvesting side of the industry and then
you go on to be on up the chain to
retail so so you said the four companies
that are on 85% whether is Tyson food
Cardinal jbs national beef those are the
four you're talking about right yes amar
Singh yep okay so those four that you're
talking about where did they fall under
those processes are data producers the
processor the distributors or retailers
obviously they're not they're the
processors and distributors they're the
processors and the distributors and is
it fair to say that they're not
necessarily the small business owners
there - you know too-big-to-fail type of
models in your world it's not a pretty -
credit okay so how do they bully you
around as the small business owner
because maybe they can afford to go
through six months of bad times where a
lot of folks in your world cannot so
what role did they play making it
difficult for you well they have taken
away all competitions so with the
acquisitions and mergers over the last
25 or 30 years they had gained more more
power and control and that has
eliminated the competition so let's say
30 years ago there would have been 800
processors across the United States able
to to process and harvest this beef
where now there are only four main
processors that harvest 85% of that
chain so what they have done is they've
totally eliminated cash competition
right and what that does is that has
created their power to go network down
and take control of the industry that
way again so how does that affect me
because imagine the consumer is one
dimensional thinker and here's what I
mean the consumer says is the meat good
is it healthy for my kids is it gonna be
cheap check I'm good to go
why should I to consumer be so concerned
about what's going on
because there's a concentration so
there's an oligarchy of power and
control at the at the top of the food on
top of the chain right and that trickles
down to you so they are able to
eliminate competition in the United
States while bringing in Cheaper lower
quality meat from other countries
eighteen other countries and they can
put that on top of our meat mix it in
the grind or mix it in you know you can
go to the grocery store and you may have
you may buy a cut of beef that says
product to the USA that does not mean
that it is a product of the USA so
basically what I'm telling you is as a
consumer you don't know what you're
buying you don't know the food safety
because every country has different
safety inspection standards right now
they do have to go through a United
States inspection standard but it's not
up to par as what we have inland here so
how it affects you is is you're getting
a lower quality product have maybe a
higher price because they as a consumers
at a higher price but that ability for
them to import that cheaper cheaper cut
of meat throw it in to the American
product it oppresses our prices because
there's no competition for it so out of
those 18 countries are any one of them
China yes
one of the 18 is China yes what
percentage recently made we we made the
trade with China on this and this was
gonna this was supposed to have been
started that you know during this coated
deal the four main trade is Canada
Mexico New Zealand and Australia now
Canada and Mexico they had a decent
relationship with the beef that was
coming in until you know the
organization which the acronym is cool
Co L which some like them some don't
like them and that kind of changed again
what happened there politically behind
closer is that the average person
doesn't know about so a mandatory
country of origin labeling was
implemented I think in 2002
somewhere around in there and what that
did was it required our processors to
put a country of a rigid label on all
beef so that means you were able to
differentiate your beef as a consumer in
the retail store what happened was is
Canada and Mexico decided that mandatory
who violated several trade agreements
and so they went to the World Trade
Organization and a lawsuit came about
the World Trade Organization determined
that it was unfair trade practices by
the United States to require mandatory
country of origin labeling Canada and
Mexico won that lawsuit and Congress
repealed mandatory cruel in 2015 now
politically who's behind cool who is
behind country of original original
original labeling because to me as a
buyer I was having lunch today with my
wife and Kai and I said babe when you
buy the meat do you care where it's from
he says oh I I don't pay attention to
but it's an important where it comes
from
she says should I be serious about it I
said babe I'm just asking you we buy
meat all the time do you ever look at
the label you see where it's coming from
she said no I don't but as a buyer
myself I kind of would want to know
where it's coming from I I don't think
it's a big deal to say you know if I'm
buying a product on the bottom it says
Made in China or Made in you know
whatever it is I also kind of want to
know where my meat is coming from why is
it such a big deal where people are
given a push back of where the meat is
coming from okay that becomes a very
complicated issue
so obviously the the main for packing
conglomerates or that oligarchy do not
want to have to differentiate that meat
they say it's too expensive to do that
to differentiate it in the pack in the
packing plant so those processors are
members of the board of directors of
what they call the National Cattlemen's
Beef Association a very strong cattle
industry lobbying group and so they have
determined that
mandatory cool is bad for the consumer
and bad for kept the cattle business the
organization called our keV us say is
organization full or comprised of
independent producers across the United
States almost 6,000 members and they
believe mandatory cool is a is an
individual right is a liberty issue and
so they're the ones that are have been
and I'm a part of that group and we have
you know spent years and years pushing
that because we believe number one it's
a liberty issue number two the data
shows that the prime of you know when
Congress repealed cool
we were in the prime of the industry we
had we were very prosperous at the time
and then as soon as it was repealed
everything fell out of bed and it went
backwards so but the National
Cattlemen's Beef Association they they
are against mandatory country-of-origin
labeling they are very Pro export very
Pro Packer and they kind of its kind of
to me it's kind of a pay-to-play system
you know the backers playing hey I'm
sitting on the board of directors and
then they get to play that they're
required to play how the Packers want
how much how much similarity is there
with your world and big pharma meaning
Big Pharma's got the lobbyists were the
biggest lobby very similar very similar
okay
very similar it's a power in control
it's all about money power and control
lobbying power now shad how many of you
are there in America meaning how many
people like you cattle ranchers how many
of you are there in America 700,000
700,000 what was it before was it a lot
more 1979 there was well about 1.2 to
1.3 million in between we went from 1.2
to 1.3 million to 700,000 today from
1979 that's correct
what was the biggest drop-off shat from
79 to today was there a single event
that got who got rid a lot of people in
your world no it was there wasn't a
single module it's a gradual decline
because of the lack of cop
throughout the industry and so we have
these acquisitions and mergers take
place more power control and you know
expenses go up we're not able to create
any kind of competition in the
marketplace and you know how stuff flows
downhill if there's ten business owners
that are selling their industry meaning
come get involved in my industry one
industry real estate one industry is
technology one industry is insurance and
other industries finance another
industry is you know construction then
you're standing there and you're selling
your industry could you easily sell
others to consider getting into your
industry today it's financially
impossible as an individual it's
financially impossible to give you say
that why do you say that because the
overhead it costs too much to start a
there you know it takes a lot of land it
takes a lot of overhead and unless you
what they proverbial term in the beef
cattle industry is is unless you marry
it or inherited you ain't going to have
it so and that's one of the problems
that has taken place as the result of
this you know it's hard for family you
know everybody's dream is to pass the
family farmer ranch down and that's
that's totally impossible now you can't
do it you know let's take me for example
you know my mom and dad had four small
nice ranches paid for in the early 80s
the early 80s come on and you know if
you worry you may not remember this
interest rates got up there seventeen to
twenty one percent there was a fall out
we lose some land well then we basically
have to start over and it's just been an
issue of that several times since then
and it's just I mean these young kids it
is impossible to get a startup you can
get some government help as a first-time
landowner or business owner but the this
the the cost of the land it requires a
lot of land and the cost of the the
inputs are increasing and gaining and
it's so it's impossible without a lot of
equity
or cash in the bank to get a start it's
nearly impossible and therefore across
America we have seen thousands and
thousands hundreds of thousands of youth
not return to the family operation after
after high school or college because of
this specific reason
correct so based on what you know I mean
I'm assuming you're in a community where
you're with other people and you're
talking to other catholic cattle
ranchers because you're in that world I
mean insurance I talk to other insurance
seals and exec yes how many of these 700
thousand you think are going to be able
to withstand the current challenges
they're facing that's a that's a good
question and I would say that we could
lose through this covert situation we
could lose plus one-third of those this
year you you could lose a third so we
can go from 700,000 to 450,000 in the
next six seven months it is possible
maybe more are you being asked to
actually kill the cattle are you being
asked no we are not being asked and I
and I pray that that we do not come to
that and I don't think we will in
America you know it's a different time
than it was 6070 years ago but you know
so to see their Dustin off the books and
the protocol is there if it has to take
place and and I want the public to
understand it we have the cleanest
safest most humane food supply in the
world but real life takes over and real
life has taken over during the Cova deal
so what has happened is with the backup
or the backlog the bottleneck of live
cattle on the hood that and that can
actually move around and Moo has backed
up to an enormous amount of numbers that
is just staggering well they have a life
span that must end at some times so when
you're when they're in the feedlot and
they're getting ready to be harvested at
the end of that when they're ready to be
harvest there is a period of time where
they can go on past
for a few weeks and they can get by but
there will come a time that those those
cattle have to have to meet in the
supply chain I mean it's it's an ugly
real-life issue that has to take place
so we are not euthanizing cattle at this
point and I don't think we will the
president put in an executive order that
was outstanding and required those
supply chains to be running so we'll see
what happens from there
right chef how many employees you have
working for you right now how many what
how many total employees did you have
pre kovat zero Oh pre pre : zero I it is
me and my widowed mother we run our
operation between Texas and Colorado she
stays on the ranch in Colorado I'm down
here and I have one older sister that
has retired from her job and moved home
she's never been married and she's kind
of helping with my mom now as my mom is
aging and getting elderly and so she
helps up there but we don't have any
employees what are your long-term plans
what you see what's going on right now
what do you thinking when you and your
mom are having conversation what do you
thinking you seem like you're young you
seem in your late 30s early 40s what are
your plans that's a great question
Patrick we you know if this was the year
2014 I would say the future is in our
hands right what we're gonna be able to
get some of this through we're just
going to start being able to buy a
little bit more land where we were
debt-free all of that came to fruition
and then and with the Congress taking
mandatory country of original labeling
away and there was a flood of cattle on
the market due to a drought the prices
just collapsed and to be honest we have
not made any money since 2014 on cattle
and so I don't know what our future
holds to be honest with you I you know I
own a little bit of land my mom owns the
you know a good portion of land she
doesn't have any cash in the bank the
land is her cash we have equity in the
land you know heard my dad started in
1959 and put this all together they
started from the ground up and they want
to pass that legacy on to their kids and
I am Warren Isle I have four three
sisters and I have warned my sisters I
said you know she has no cash we're not
making money we've pulled a rabbit out
of the hat to get by the last four years
it is the possibility that we could have
to sell the land for you know if she was
to have to go the nursing home or
something like that so you've actually
considered now you actually had that
conversation with your three sisters we
are having it more and more every day
it's just a tough industry to be in and
if you're not profitable it's not good I
mean you know we're we're spending let's
say we're spending twelve hundred
dollars a head to make nine hundred
dollars a head that's terrible business
we love the life we love the legacy but
at some point you have to draw the line
and say okay are we going to be business
people and are we going to lose
everything we've put together over the
last sixty years and go from there I
don't know I think you have to be a
business person you have to be smart and
you have to be real you know they don't
see legacy they don't see family they
don't see tradition they don't see any
of that stuff they don't know the
stories you have with your pops and the
lessons you're gonna pass down to your
four-year-old son they just see profit
margin that's all they see you're trying
and well one thing our CAF USA did in
April 2000 nineteen is we filed an
antitrust lawsuit against those four
main Packers it was historic in nature
and right now we're in the motion to
dismiss they're in the motion to dismiss
phase of that lawsuit but if that
lawsuit goes through that will be
historic in terms of the industry and it
could change the industry by itself we
are you know clamoring and hollering and
but you know there's two factions in our
industry there's the independent
producer and then there's the globalist
and those two factions are fighting
right now
for our industry sonny perdue our
secretary of agriculture head of the
United States Department of Agriculture
has done more harm to the agricultural
industry as a whole than any other
Secretary of Agriculture in the history
of our nation we have lost over 50
percent of our net farm income under his
watch
he's a globalist and we're working hard
to get president Trump's ear I mean
every day we got letters letters letters
we're calling and calling we have people
on our side and after my video I'll tell
you I think the video changed a little
bit of the mindset of the American
consumer they they now see they depend
on others for their supply right their
food supply and I think now with the
Kovach deal and the backlog of Prout of
product across the nation they see that
they need to take more responsibility in
it and I think it's a great thing you
have kids yes I have one stepdaughter
Lindsay and I have a four year old
little boy any plans of one day one and
to pass this down to your stepdaughter
on your son absolutely that's the goal
you know we that is every ranchers dream
is to be able to pass these this
business and this lifestyle it's a
tradition it's something that we love it
brings a lot of hardship that it brings
a lot of love to the heart too you know
that there's a lot of rewarding
experiences in this life and it's more
it's it's I shouldn't say it's not about
the money because we have to be able to
feed the world in a profit we can't do
it at a loss and in order to you know
send that dream on down the road we have
to be successful and you know we do want
to want it as our legacy that's what
it's all about is your legacy we're
proud to be multi-generational operators
but at this point it's not looking like
it and I'm telling you why why did it
why would I want my son to go through a
life of misery because you know as a
very competitive person we're very
competitive people but at some point you
have to
Wyn and winds are coming so few and far
between because remember the cattle
producers are not just at the mercies of
the market and the corruption there at
the mercies of the weather they're at
the mercies of droughts and floods and
blizzards you know take for example
those producers up in Nebraska and South
Dakota in the in the winter of 2018 19
went through blizzard after blizzard
they lost a million head of cattle well
when you're losing your livelihood and
then they gut punch you with market
collapses it's hard to take so you know
sure I believe the future is is positive
I want to believe it is positive that
you know the route the reality is is
there's not a great future for
independent producers across the country
Chad how much of your fondest memories
of you and your father has to do with
you guys working together on the ranch I
you know I I've been here I'm 46 years
old I went to college for four years and
that's the only time I was ever away we
us we were a little different my mom and
dad were putting all of this together
took some hard hits in the 80s again in
1990 kind of set us back we recovered
from those but me and my siblings we
were all a part of this we helped build
this and my dad's dream god bless him
was to was to allow us to capture some
of this pride you know some of this
success so yeah all of my memories I
mean he taught me everything I know we
went through good and bad we you know I
that I could tell you so many stories
and make your head swim right that's a
that's the beautiful part of our legacy
business you know when you get to work
with your data and you share those
stories with your son and wonder your
four-year-old son runs this and your
father essentially is living through you
know his grandson so no couple questions
on the complete opposite side some may
say the consumer may say you know the
price of beef
from 416 and 2015 to 378 today which is
a 10% drop-off right and remember the
consumer is very one-dimensional the
consumer doesn't go to the stories the
consumer doesn't remember what you and
your father did the consumer is thinking
about if I can send 10 cents or 10% I'll
go to Target over Walmart I don't care
who's getting my business I just need to
save my money but you guys lost 40
percent during that period so again the
price went down 10% but your business
margins went down 40% correct well I
guess the question becomes the following
why should the consumer be concerned
about you losing 30% to want to buy the
product from you versus going and saving
that 10% that they're gonna get
themselves because if as an individual
producer I go to out of business that
makes them rely upon the multinational
corporations to provide their be their
food supply not just me that their food
supply all around and we know what
they've already done is lower the
quality of beef coming into the country
being imported into the country and the
consumer doesn't know where that food
safety issue lies they need to have the
choice to do that and if I'm gone as an
individual Perdue yes sir who's who
fills my shoes now in this time and
ain't nobody nobody only multinational
corporations the conglomerates the
control why should the consumer care
because it's a food safety issue okay so
that's what I'm going okay so if it's a
food safety issue if it's a food safety
issue you're saying buying meat from
outside of the United States is not as
safe as buying to me that's a mini
United States I would say that as a
personal human being absolutely we have
the highest quality beef supply the
safest beasts employee we've we've spent
the last hundred and fifty years
improving our herds we have the best
beef available on the planet we want
that to be differentiated from those
people who have not worked so hard to be
to be in the US market you know USA beef
is the best product in the world there's
no there's no other
is comparable we have the safest and the
the highest quality beef in the world
and I I hope the consumers realize that
and I hope they choose that and will pay
a little bit more money to local people
to do that
I'm afford to small business owner but I
also know you know Tyson JB these guys
are gonna come out I'm you and her JB us
was trying to buy national beef back in
Oh nine that would have been a whole big
monopoly and Jamie the Brazilian based
company which makes no sense for let's
talk about that Patrick because jbs and
national maar Frigg are both Brazilian
owned jbs is both owned by the paddy
Bautista family Jos Lee and Wesley are
the two brothers that are heads of that
corporation and those people those
brothers just got out of prison in
Brazil for fraud and unfair market or
trade practices in their country they
just got out of prison both of those
boys spent two years a year in prison
for fraud they in 2017 jbs if we were
importing Brazilian beef they said not
us they sent it all over the world
rotten meat they got caught in a scandal
it is a food safety issue like no other
and when you have to I mean we're
selling our souls to other countries
we're depending on other countries the
same way with China everybody's talking
this week about all of their medical
supplies coming from China right nobody
knew that I didn't know that I tell you
I I'm on a weekly regimen of
chemotherapy and have been for a year
and a half we don't I don't know where
that comes from I never thought about it
right so now we have all these people
don't know where their food supply is
coming from and there it's all a safety
issue right I mean when two of our four
main beef packers are Brazilian own
foreign own and they have that much
power and they've been caught in these
fraudulent cases in their own countries
what do you think they're doing the
United States right they don't care
about the American consumer and I'm not
against the American dream I love this
guy gets art out small gets big and
grows big I think it's I think that's
awesome but this isn't that
this is this is a corruption and when
people say shad what would you do to
change the industry I start at the top
and I say we gotta end corruption we
have to we have enforced the Packers and
stockyards act of 1921 which guaranteed
a level playing field for the producer
cleared of the pattern we have to
enforce antitrust laws that we have on
the books that keep these acquisitions
and murders from happening we have these
laws why aren't they being implemented
why is the federal government allowing
the acquisitions and mergers to gain
control because it's a part of a
globalist economy a global economy and
I'm fine with the global economy but
it's got to be fair for the producer
it's got to be parrot fair for the
independent producer of the United
States any producers whether you're
pretty missing rocky chairs or counts
right the American Dream is about
private property rights without your
ability to own private property rights
or to own private property whether it's
land or a business in town you don't
have the ability to be a part of a free
market system capitalistic system and
these are all private property rights
that are being taken away from this day
by day how Howard Howe well let's let's
let's take for example there's in
production agriculture there's these new
measures called the global roundtables
and let's take the specific one that I
know deeply about is called the global
roundtable for sustainable B and what
that is is that is was created by the
United Nations it they implemented this
control mechanism called the global
round table for sustainable beef they
implemented it across the world through
the World Wildlife Fund the World
Wildlife Fund is a environmental
organization that does not believe in
private property rights they're they're
a very enormous lis money driven
organization that wants to take you off
off your land so they have implemented
this deal called the global roundtable
for sustainable beef and it controls
production standards from top to bottom
so what it does is
they they come in at the top of the
chain the supply chain and they say okay
you're gonna produce this this this at
this cost
you're gonna implement these production
standards you're going to do this to
your cattle you're gonna do this to your
land they're gonna have third parties
that come in and audit it and then and
then and so then they have you captured
and it creates bottleneck and if you
don't get on board you you are not
allowed to play in the market and that
has already come to fruition in Brazil
under the global roundtable for
sustainable soy in 2016 they implemented
that and a whole host and I won't say
how many of those Brazilian soybean
farmers declined to be a part of the
global roundtables for sustainable soy
they were kicked out of the market and
many of them committed suicide these are
control communistic methods that have
you embrace you buy the net they take
you by the neck and you are going to
adhere to their production standards
from top to bottom or you're not going
to be in the system so question for you
there are three organizations it seems
like in your world I don't know if you
can see it or not WTO cool and USDA
right USDA's and you got cool which is
the country of origin of labeling those
cool is not cool is not an organization
cool it means country overage and
labeling that is not an organization at
all job yeah correct
okay so if you have the USDA and the
World Trade Organization correct can you
give us in another industry like World
Trade Organization I get it so World
Trade Organization fine we kind of know
who to compare them to World Health
Organization WTO wh I think they're
pretty Iran in a similar way right let's
put those guys aside right there's USDA
and other industry if you were to say
USDA in a different industry as such and
such and such organization so we can
kind of have a parallel well the USDA is
is head over the agriculture industry
right it's the government
CSEC for financial erect that's correct
our did politically driven or not at all
well they're not supposed to be
politically driven but the fruits of
their labor has showed that they are a
bit politically driven you know we have
we have screamed and yelled for
mandatory country-of-origin labeling and
they have gone against us we have
screamed and yelled on August 19th 2019
there was a fire in a packing facility
at Tyson meat packing plant in southwest
Kansas it decimated our markets
overnight overnight we were in trouble
we asked the usda and sonny perdue who
is the director you know Secretary of
Agriculture to investigate that price
collapse due to that fire one fire in
one plant decimated our prices in one
night overnight and we asked for those
investigations to take place and until
we the independent producers put
pressure on sonny Perdue the Secretary
of Agriculture and the United States
Department of Agriculture nothing
happened there was no action they are
now now because so many people have
spoke up they are now supposedly in an
investigation but it's been nine months
and we have not heard one thing about
that investigation where it stands or
anything largest contributor to World
Trade Organization is USA but we give
the most first place with 11% second is
China with 9% how much similarities is
there with WTO and W in a World Health
Organization with China trying to also
control some of the decision-making to
get more business funnel from China
coming in to us I don't know I can't
answer I was just curious if there's any
kind of a political move being made
there on that side so you go out to
dinner this Friday night let's just say
the market opens up restaurants open up
you go to dinner you're ordering steak
what kind of steak are you ordering I'm
ordering a filet mignon or a ribeye and
do you ask specifically about the meat
and equality to meat I asked
specifically what country it originated
and most of the time they cannot tell me
you're being serious yes Wow and if they
can't tell you what do they say they say
I don't know most of those good cuts
hopefully are you know let's let's take
for example you go to a high-end
Steakhouse in Fort Worth those that
that's gonna be American beef I mean
that's there's probably no questions
that but then if you get down into the
chain steak houses there might be a
question to it I'm hopeful that that is
all American beef and I think it is yes
but then when you go let's say you're
ordering a hamburger for McDonald's
likely it's not it's not American beef
you're not in let's just say you're not
in your world you're just an advisor to
people I want to eat healthy to help me
is you want to educate them to ask the
right questions what questions should we
be asking us consumers well I think the
consumer is if the consumer is going
into a grocery store or a steakhouse I
think the first thing they should ask is
where does my meat you come from where
does this beef come from I think that is
so important because it creates Liberty
in for the consumer people often say we
don't want the government getting in on
our beef industry okay well we are
already taxed one dollar per head every
time we sell an animal we have to give
the government one dollar okay her head
we have requirements they're trying to
implement what they call the radio
frequency identification system into the
beef industry that's government
involvement but the difference is is
mandatory cool becomes a little-bitty
issue because it's a law that provides
freedom and liberty to the consumer to
make a choice that we've created law
from the beginning of our country to
enable the consumer to have choice right
so that's that's a good law but these
other laws that they want to implement
such as the beef checkoff is the one
dollar text that's taxation without
representation as far as I'm concerned
radio frequency identification tags in
these cattle what that is is the chip
that goes into the cow they want to know
about
from birth to plate that that actually
inhibits liberty and freedom to the
producer because it's a private property
rights as she right so they they want to
know everything you're doing well in
America we're supposed to be able to
produce how we see fit and and let the
consumer take that choice out move that
choice down the chain very very
interesting so last question here before
I go to a comparison I'll make an and
we'll wrap up is say you leave the
business let's say you leave the
business you're not in the business
anymore and there's a couple hundred
thousand other people that also leave
the business where do they go to what do
they do next I don't know you seriously
don't know no a guy like me um I can get
a job somewhere you know it's not the
job you're gonna want but we have to do
things we don't want to do because we
have to put food on the table for our
family and most people are like that but
what will happen is there will be a
takeover of our industry the property
will become under ownership you know
some of these guys might not lose all
this property but the ability to produce
on it is lost because it's unaffordable
so what happens is the Oleg Archy takes
over the industry down the supply chain
and then a lot of these producers will
become excuse me will become serfs to
the old oligarchy and I think that's
where we're headed you're out of the
industry you're speaking out of
conference there's 10,000 people at this
event they hired you to tell them what
to do for them to separate themselves
from their competitors to make it in
your industry okay again you're a
consultant you're no longer shad Solomon
the American cattle rancher you have
decided to go be a consultant for your
industry okay and you're talking to a
convention with 10,000 of these guys
that do what you do and they're asking
you chef how do I differentiate myself
against my competitors right now to have
an upper advantage what would you tell
them hmm well I go back to what my mom
and dad taught me that was to work hard
and never give up that's what I tell
them because it's all about work we work
hard every single day we take the good
with the bad I can
remember my dad telling me shad you got
to take the good with the bad
and that's what I I mean I asked that
question because you're saying spent
twelve hundred dollars to make nine
hundred dollars that's not a business
model no that's not a business how do
you I'm a guy that's spending to a
hundred to making nine hundred what do
you tell me shad you can't tell me what
card I come from a family we all worked
hard what the hell so then guess what
happens do you have to make choices you
have to you know think outside of the
box there's a lot of people in this
industry that have great minds but ma
I'll tell you a lot of this industry are
two or two income families I mean the
wife is gonna have to go to work in town
to pay that just to pay the bills but
you see we're losing so much money now
used to that would work a little bit but
we're losing so much equity now that
that even with the second off farm job
it's not working so what I tell people I
would tell people I see you got a word
you've got to get faith and you never
give up you never give up there are
smart people in this industry incredibly
smart people they're innovative that's
why we have the best product in the
world it says these people are
innovative but not everybody can produce
the same right everybody's gonna produce
different everybody's gonna have a
different idea so my dad always said if
it ain't broke don't try to fix it you
know if it's working keep doing it and
we've been at that we've been at this
exact same operation for the last 4050
years and haven't changed but it worked
up until 2015 and in so I don't know
we're gonna keep we're gonna keep
working hard we're gonna have faith in
God and we're not gonna give up because
that's what he asks us to do you know
you know what it reminds me of here's
what it reminds me of it reminds me of
when Walmart first came out in 1962 and
a half with target and when all these
Kmart it was the super savings center
nineteen sixty two and a half and
Walmart started getting bigger and
bigger and bigger and a lot of the local
small mom-and-pop shop in a small city
you know that no one knows about Walmart
came in and they're selling milk for
price and Walmart's got a 20% cheaper
and and we started saying honey why are
we going to mama shop well instead of
going to Bob's spot let's go to Walmart
no this is a lot cheaper place is it
similar to what Walmart did to a lot of
mom-and-pop shops and put them out of
business it's the same thing it's the
absolutely and you have to remember
80% of rural America is is a no
stoplight town right these cities these
rural towns the flower shop depends on
the farmer and rancher the tire store
depends on the farmers ranchers the
school especially depends on the farmer
and rancher and when these people leave
this lead production those things in the
grocery store ends everything ends in
those small towns and that's why it's so
important that we get competition back
in our business who's the Amazon of your
world
who's the Amazon not the Walmart who's
the Amazon of your world I'm not sure
there is an Amazon of our world maybe
there's an idea right there you know
maybe there's an idea right there I
don't know if you're talking about
there's a lot of innovative guys and you
got to figure out a way to pivot maybe
I'm changing my business model and
seeing because when Walmart was bullying
everybody and nobody thought anybody
could go after them thank him a guy
named Jeff who said hey I'm gonna come
after in a different way and he did and
now Amazon is scaring the hell out of
Walmart along with Nestle people to
compete with Amazon so I just think
there's an opportunity for some like
this to decide to pivot and go in
different in your world to give you
counsel I'm just kidding all right where
you were gonna go with that shat we wish
you nothing but the best thank you so
much we're spending 30 minutes here with
us thank you so much I appreciate the
time and I just wish everybody go to us
demand us a beef com sign the petition
to enforce mandatory country-of-origin
labeling I'd like to tell that tell your
listeners since my video I've had
hundreds of thousands of messages asking
where can we get our beef on a local
level well our CAF USA has come up with
a website called USA beef org and you
can go there and it will commingle you
with producers all across the nation
there's 350 producers from 40 states you
can get it there and to learn more about
mandatory country of origin go to label
our beef calm and you can learn more
about it there
we're gonna put both links below I
actually went on the website with the
350 different of them and I saw how it
was it's very user friendly again we'll
put the link below for you to go visit
it shadow one so much for being a guest
Thank You Patrick
he's buddy cattle rancher shad Sullivan
did he influenced you to ask the
question of where is this meat from I'm
actually curious to know if it's gonna
change your way of buying and shopping
when it comes out to me comment below
and if you enjoyed this interview I did
another video because I talked about
Walmart against Amazon the award that
they have the five trillion dollar war
if you've not seen this video it's very
very interesting why some believe
Walmart is going to come back and
compete with Amazon if you've not
watched it click on this link to watch
the video and if you're not subscribed
to the channel please do so thanks for
watching everybody take care bye bye
[Music]